philippe thellier bonsoir du comité
catholique contre la faim et pour le
développement terre solidaire membres de
l'antenne de saint quentin en yvelines
vous êtes l'un des onze mille bénévoles
de cette organisation première ong
française de développement avant de
parler plus en détails de l'action que
vous préparez sur magny les hameaux à
partir du 10 novembre
je vais vous laisser déjà présenté
justement le ccfd plus en détail sa
création remonte à 1961 exactement c'est
une ong qui a été créée à l'initiative
des évêques de france et où à l'époque
qu'il s'agissait de lutter contre la
faim dans le monde et on a rajouté le
terme développement parce qu'on
souhaitait aussi promeut promouvoir le
développement des pays du sud et de
l'est à travers les actions dispensés
par le ccfd trois axes un soutenir ses
projets de développement humain dans des
pays en développement lors du sud et de
l'est en france et sensibiliser
l'opinion qui n'oblige c'est ce que vous
allez faire à magny les hameaux et très
prochainement à l'opinion publique à la
situation des pays pauvres par
l'éducation développement et puis
obtenir aussi des règles internationales
plus juste et bien en menant des actions
de plaidoyer auprès des décideurs
politiques et économiques
exactement sears est une ong qui agit
aussi sur les causes on n'est pas une
ong urgentistes et donc on met le doigt
sur les causes du mal développement
comme par exemple les paradis fiscaux et
le film qui sera présenté le 17 novembre
au soir par la maison de l'environnement
voilà et où il y aura un débat qui
suivra ce film pour évoquer les méfaits
de ces paradis fiscaux dans les pays
d'afrique notamment puisqu'on axe
cette exposition sur la région des
grands lacs et donc c'est l'un des trois
axes en effet que nous mettons en avant
le prix du loyer et le doigt sur les
causes du mal développement justement
sensibiliser l'opinion publique
vous entendez pas par une politique
d'éducation au développement
alors eh bien il s'agit d'intervenir par
exemple dans les milieux scolaire en
collège
en lycée on est tout à fait autorisé par
le ministère de l'éducation à intervenir
au sein des classes pour sensibiliser
les jeunes au développement des pays
pauvres et la façon dont on vit ici en
france peut avoir des conséquences sur
leur mal vivre là-bas et toutes ces
actions sont menées par des membres de
la communauté chrétienne uniquement non
alors à ses patients que principalement
c'est une ong qui est ouvert à toutes
confessions ont peut être de toutes
confessions ont peut être aussi non
malgré le nom c'est comité catholique
contre la faim exactement le
développement mais c'est ouvert à tous
et on soutient d'ailleurs des
partenaires de toutes confessions aussi
là-bas dans tous les pays du sud est et
de l'est vous avez rejoint le mouvement
qu'en bon là s'il serait en 86 pour
comment ça s'est fait pourquoi vous avez
c'est bien en fait j'ai été témoin d'un
d'une théâtre itinérant qui parlait de
la vie de montigny romeo qui et qui a
été assassinée en pleine messe pour
avoir osé dénoncer les méfaits de la
dictature chez lui au salvador et qu'il
est intervenu dans son serment pour
empêcher des actes de violence de la
part des militaires et on est venu
l'assassiner en pleine messe à ce moment
là j'ai trouvé que c'était une ville
magnifique et que le ccfd soutiennent
les populations locales notamment
d'amérique du sud
dans ces conditions là ils parient sur
un projet extrêmement intéressant ça a
été l'élément déclencheur pour vous
voilà cette occasion pour cet engagement
il n'y a pas de petite réussite c'est le
slogan de cette ong chaque opération
aussi petite soit elle est importante a
mené exactement par exemple on a une
filiale qui s'appelle la cidi au sein du
ccfd qui permet de dispenser les
micro-crédits des chefs d'entreprises
parce que on veut montrer à travers
l'exposition dont on parle qu' il ne
faut pas avoir des idées toutes faites
et notamment ne pas avoir un regard
misérabiliste sur ces populations qui se
prennent en charge et qui tous les jours
montrent des entreprises réussissent des
actions
entreprennent des des actions pour se
protéger contre les méfaits par rapport
aux droits de l'homme qui ne sont pas
respectés qu'ils font en sorte qu'il y
ait une meilleure éducation qu'il y ait
du logement plus salubre qui est un
développement de l'agriculture locale
voilà donc tout ce qui peut permettre un
pays de se développer
eh bien ils le font et nous céder on
aide des projets que les acteurs eux
mêmes ont choisi c'est à dire ce n'est
pas nous qui allons imposer nos vues et
notre façon de voir vous apporter des
fonds et les structures pour aider en
tout cas exactement et on va les
rencontrer on fait venir aussi des
partenaires en france il ya 50 est
régulièrement tous les ans pour qu'il
vienne parler leur projet qui le montre
un petit peu concrètement ce qui est
réalisé sur le terrain et pour tout ça
vous avez besoin de récolter des dons il
ya cette action à manning et amoa vente
de toiles de peinture du 10 au 30
novembre a commencé ses mises en place
par dont cette opération alors il se
trouve que je fais aussi partie d'une
association qui s'appelle vocation
pastel qui est basée à
voisins-le-bretonneux qui compte 60
membres et qui n'avait pas cette année
de locaux pour faire son exposition
annuelle du fait de travaux dans la
ville de voisins et du coup j'avais une
possibilité à travers le ccfd d'offrir
grâce à la maison l'environnement et du
développement durable de manioc et magny
les hameaux les avions retenu
une manifestation sur le film et bien
j'avais cette possibilité d'offrir
vocation pastel une salle pour exposer
et toiles sont mises en vente
alors voilà on s'est basé sur une
expérience des ardéchois du ccfd qui
avait fait le premier salon de toiles
solidaire en 2011 où il avait interpellé
des peintres pour abandonner leurs
oeuvres et mettre en vente au profit du
ccfd c'est ce que j'ai proposé à
vocation pastel et spontanément beaucoup
de membres ont bien voulu créer des
oeuvres spécialement pour le ccfd sur le
thème de l'afrique puisque on parle
beaucoup de la région des grands lacs en
ce moment et les abandonnent leurs
oeuvres au profit de cette exposition
dont les fonds serviront à alimenter les
projets soutenus par le ccfd par exemple
quel projet concrètement cet argent que
vous allez récolter alors être envoyée à
tous les projets qui permettent de
travailler les actions pour la paix
puisque vous savez que autour des grands
lacs il y a le rwanda le burundi le rdc
république démocratique du congo où on
est à peine sorti du génocide
et tout ça est encore plus ou moins aux
conflits armés donc au travail à ce
qu'il y ait des projets qu'ils fassent
en sorte que la paix s'établisse tous
les jours et aussi au développement de
l'agriculture locale
donc il y à toute une liste de projet
qui est financé par cela alors ce que je
voulais dire aussi c'est que je tenais à
souligner la bonne volonté enfin en tout
cas extraordinaire élan de générosité
des peintre pastelliste qui se sont mis
à réaliser ses oeuvres spécialement pas
spécialement justement pour les ong pour
vous puissiez récolter des fonds et mené
les actions dont vous nous parliez ce
soir juste pour conclure le mot sur
cette soirée du 17 novembre on en a déjà
parlé un petit peu de à travers
l'entretien depuis une dizaine de
minutes documentaire zambie à qui
profite le cuivre
voilà c'est à dire que c'est une grosse
multinationale suisse qui exploite cette
mine et dans des conditions qui sont pas
du tout à la faveur de la population
locale puisque
il n'y a aucun respect de
l'environnement l'eau la terre et l'air
et sont pollués et on a des cancers en
syrie des affections pulmonaires très
grave et en plus c'est une
multinationale qui profitent des paradis
fiscaux pour ne pas payer jurés les
impôts qu'ils doivent à la zambie et
donc ça empêche la zambie de se
développer
et donc c'est tout cela qu'on dénonce et
notamment actuellement le ccfd réussi à
intervenir auprès de nos représentants
notamment il ya une commission
sénatoriale en semant qui travaille à
faire en sorte qu'il y ait plus de
transparence dans les comptes des
multinationales françaises notamment
pour empêcher ces dérives projection de
ce documentaire débat également l entrée
est libre
c'est à la maison de l'environnement à
magny les hameaux le 17 novembre et puis
du 10 au 30 novembre 7,25 de toile juste
a ajouté que le 17 novembre après midi
il ya un atelier d'initiation au pastel
pour les enfants
évocation pastel animera cet après midi
là merci philippe thellier donc dû à ces
cdf terre solidaire d'être venu nous
parler de cette opération sur magny les
hameaux dans les yvelines merci à vous
on va changer de sujet à présent quelles
activités pour les enfants pendant les
vacances